we heart celebrities and with services
like cameo you can even send
personalized video messages from some of
today's hottest celebs a man that this
is John from John and Kate Plus eight
now you can get painfully close to the
stars without snap and it's a snap to
use just cruise our talent then check
out how they'll injure you for that
sweet Southie for just forty dollars
Hawaii five-o start Scott Caan will push
you out of your chair Wow
for $85 taraji P Henson will smash your
legs with a metal pipe tight for a
hundred and nine dollars you can have
your house burned down by Mark Ruffalo
so bless and for two hundred and fifty
dollars the original members of Wilson
Phillips will kick you within inches of
your life your friends will have FOMO
when Tim Gunn puts you in a coma want
frankie muniz to slam a dictionary on
your hand want the cash me outside girl
to poison your dog or once is go to bite
your dad how much would you pay to get
shoved by the president
get that selfie snaps stat with our snap
what's the worst that could happen
how's that response
[Applause]
you